the first major automotive trade fair of
the year is kicked off and the cheap
price of fuel in the u.s. is reviving an
old trend once again American customers
are buying bigger cars with beefed up
motors that's why it's surprising that
VW was granted the coveted north
american car of the year award at the
beginning of the event a panel of 57
u.s. and Canadian base car journalists
gave the Gulf the laurels the compact
class German vehicle beat its closest
competitor soundly including an American
model that's just as legendary the Ford
Mustang
esma's the fantastic president and CEO
of VW America said the prize confirms
the company is on the right path with
the Gulf even in a market that is
generally dominated by SUVs pickups and
sedans and the German carmaker also
brought its latest and greatest to the
fair that cross coupe a gte the concept
car seeks to combine German engineering
with the American Way of life vista
boobies the parent concerns board
chairman says SUVs aren't just important
in the US but now also in Europe and
China and VW must respond that's why
it's introducing this new plug-in hybrid
with a v6 engine he thinks it will meet
customer demands debentures they
couldn't even more important than the
unveiling of the GTE was the
announcement that Volkswagen plans to
shorten its product cycle in the US in
the future models will get facelifts
every two years and the next generation
will come after five Mercedes is also
betting big on SUVs in America it's ji
le Kupe is a dynamic crossover that goes
toe-to-toe with the BMW x6 the Mercedes
SUV shares its technical platform with
the m-class in Detroit the German
manufacturer presented its most muscular
version of the vehicle the GL 63 AMG s
which can draw on 430 kilowatts of power
from a five and a half liter engine the
coop a comes with a four wheel drive as
part of the standard package
daimler's chairman of the board says the
car combines the sportiness of a coupe a
with the elegant silhouette and
advantages of an SUV it's a package
that's unbeatable he says and of course
Porsche was also at the detroit auto
show now mythic board member Matthias
Mueller reiterated how important the US
market is and said Porsha likes to come
and present its latest designs in
Detroit like here at the world premiere
of the Cayenne S turbo its reworked 4.8
liter v8 biturbo engine now it turns out
419 kilowatts of power and has 800
newton meters of torque it can hurdle to
100 kilometers an hour from a standstill
and a heart-stopping 4.1 seconds porsche
had more news with its new 911 targa for
GTS the german carmaker has for the
first time integrated as popular GTS
idea into its classic target concept
Lexus has focused on creating a sporty F
version of its midsize sedan the GS the
nose of the GSF is almost identical to
that of the Japanese carmakers RCF
sports coupe a the grill is a real eye
catcher the taillights take their cues
from two door models and a dual exhaust
gives it a dynamic player in terms of
the car itself I think there's probably
three things the standard torque
vectoring differential for handling the
the five liter naturally aspirated v8
for power and then the Brembo brakes for
stopping so I think we've got handling
going and stopping all taken care of the
eight cylinder 348 kilowatt gasoline
engine can also sprint to 100 kilometers
an hour in just over four seconds
specially designed seats both in front
and back provide the necessary support
at the show BMW is also celebrating the
launch of a new six series range not
with one model either but with three an
elegant four-door gran coupe a a sporty
412 kilowatt m6 coupe a and a snazzy
little convertible carrying a soft top
that can retract in just 19 seconds BMW
was cautious with changes after all the
Bavarian car maker has sold eighty
thousand units from the series in the
last three years alone it's also
providing a special new service for the
US market in the future BMW customers
there will be able to tailor cars in
whole new ways this works by you working
alongside a designer with special paint
special leathers special treatments and
ultimately producing a bespoke vehicle
for your individual needs your
individual requirements last but far
from least the stir the show appeared as
if by magic introducing the new audi q7
The Ellen says I feeling it the branch
chairman says Audi thought about how to
make large cars fit for the future and
successfully slip there's down the new
q7 is 325 kilos lighter than its
predecessor and is equipped with
cutting-edge drive technology like a
plug-in hybrid option the company also
reworked its entire range of engines he
says and when it comes to networking
technology howdy is top of the class
that's the demo Kunak connectivity is
kisas development boss early Hackenberg
when it comes to network services you
can do anything in this car and the
german carmaker has more planned for
2015 30 for the outing chairman says the
firm wants to keep growing and that the
foundation has been laid for that I q7
is just a start they'll be movement with
the r8 this year as well he says there's
lots of the company will be working on
so Tony La by Dantas is him a good
howdy seems to be getting it right even
the competition is apparently impressed